[music]
really It seems to harden more and become
stronger and even the fact that now
there is no light.
with candles and This adds even more atmosphere
and cozy such a mood, so
it seems to me that not only you know Well,
nothing will succeed in them because we are very
strong in spirit And if we are in spirit today,
then for sure no one will break us, then I
understand that this is the time
and  - and
I really want the world to recognize that
Russia is a terrorist country and everything
it does is terrorist attacks on the
peaceful population. Here we hope that
soon this country will not exist
[music]
if the Russians had their way Well, they achieved
nothing, we became Everything is enough spirit Yes  we will
close now, but the guests continue to
finish their meals, to enjoy
life as it is, and accordingly,
we definitely do not lose our spirit and will
continue
[music] to
people
[music]
Every day we usually prepare
standard quantities and portions of all
hot dishes, and on such days we
call them Stations
in
cooperation with the Red Cross, they
give us information
about the district victims, this is not only
when there is no electricity, but also at the
places of rocket landings. Unfortunately  and
cooperation with the Red Cross, they
give us information and we, in turn,
go to the places of such situations and
give out hot lunches for those people
who currently do not have gas or
electricity supply.
can cook and must
cook in the
postpartum ward. Mothers with babies
in the pathology ward, pregnant women,
it really doesn't work out. Thank you
Lena
[music]
From the moment we arrived, they were
brought to us on the 17th every day, twice a
day
.  when
even drink water